Thank you, sir.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us here
in these verses of
regarding the analogies that he gives
the analogies that he chooses to give
subhanahu wa ta'ala the belief system of
the mushri
before
Islam
and even the disbelievers to this day.
Human beings have a tendency
to gauge things and their significance
by physical form.
So what's important is to have a high
number of something or that something is
big and grandiose.
But this is not what Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
draws attention to whether in the Quran
or in the previous books. It's not
important how big something is. It's not
important how many a group are. It
doesn't matter how noticed it is or
unnoticed. What matters is truth and
falsehood.
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala he says
he says subhanahu wa'ta'ala
that Allah is not shy or modest to and
he is not subhanahu wa'ta'ala
innately opposed to giving an analogy
Y
based on
something's size whether it is a
mosquito or anything larger than that.
Why? Because it is about truth. If the
mosquito and its analogy holds truth,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is the
vanguard. He is subhanahua
al the one of truth.
And so in surah
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said to the
mushri,
"Oh people,
Allah is giving an analogy striking a
parable." And so listen to it.
Those who you call upon and worship
aside from Allah
They cannot create a fly
even if they all collaborated to do so.
And if the fly were to take something
from them, they would not be able to
retrieve it. Imagine with me
the greatest, most powerful king on
earth
with all of his troops and might and
technology and resources
sitting in front of a grand feast.
And a fly lands on one of the dishes
and takes a sip from one of those
dishes. This king in all his might and
in all of his glory and all of his
technology
could he retrieve that sip from the
belly of that fly after he has taken it.
The answer is no. When Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala gave this parable,
the mushri rebuttled not discussing the
point of the parable
and that is that they are worshiping
idols, worshiping people in their
graves, worshiping righteous people as
they claim, worshiping a worshiping
stones and trees and graves
and that these things that they are
worshiping cannot even help their own
selves, let alone their devotees.
Instead of dealing with that, which is
the point of the analogy, they turned
and said, "How would Allah, the great
Allah,
give an analogy about such a petty small
thing a mosquito or a fly?"
And then Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala sent
down
Why? Because the issue is an issue of
truth and falsehood, not an issue of
size or significance of that created
thing. This is an argument that has
always been used and is still used
today. If you listen to atheists or
those who try to argue away the
existence of the creator, they'll say
things like, "Look at how silly religion
is.
Look at how they, this is what they say,
that this God of yours that you all
worship must be a very petty God.
Because this God in all of his glory and
greatness, why would he care what his
little tiny tiny servant puts into his
belly or what he eats or what he does
with his private parts? What kind of a
god would care about these things? Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says
just because the the cre the creature is
small and the creature is feeble doesn't
mean that it's not an issue of truth and
falsehood. If a human being places in
his belly what is of falsehood, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala will address it. And
if the human being does with his private
parts what is of falsehood, Allah
will address it not out of pettiness but
because he is subhanahu
here in this verse in
we have a similar issue and that is that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions 19
are the caretakers and gatekeepers of
the hellfire. 18 with Madek. Madek is
their leader and their chieftain of the
gatekeepers of hell. 18 under him seven
gates and decadent levels of the
hellfire.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions that
he says and tells us of these details in
order that the people who have already
chosen disbelief become more increased
in their disbelief and misguidance so as
to separate themselves
truly and deeply from the people
of belief.
Also so that the people who were given
the book before and have knowledge of
these details know that this book that
Muhammad recites sallall.aii wasallam is
from Allah and that Muhammad is the
messenger of Allah also so that the
believers will be increased in faith.
This is a point that is mentioned often
in the Quran. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says in this verse
that every verse that Allah sends down
and every point of knowledge that Allah
makes
it is so that the believers are
increased in their belief.
What does that mean? That the believers
are increased in their belief. This is a
big misconception we have amongst us as
Muslims today
and that is the misconception
that you don't need knowledge to arrive
at Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
You don't need knowledge to gain favor
from Allah. You can be really ignorant
and make a lot of mistakes, but if your
heart's in the right place and if you
didn't know any better, then all is all
is well. All's well that ends well. This
is the idea that we have and this is a
pitiful pathetic view of what our
religion teaches us and that is that
the knowledge and revelations of Allah
when we receive them as human beings
they are a map of unknown
territories to us. They are a map of
places that we've never been and we
don't know that exist. And we can only
gain Allah's favor if we have the right
technology. If we worship Allah in the
right way. This is why he sent to us a
messenger.
The testimony of Islam is not justahill.
It's not just sincerity.
That's only one half of it. The other
half is Muhammadool Allah. It is the
legacy and the way that we worship
Allah. It's just not it's not just that
we worship Allah alone, but that we
worship Allah alone
in the way that Allah has commanded
subhanahu wa ta'ala. How many times do
we hear this throughout the Quran?
Always this is repeated through the
Quran. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in
the closing verse of
there are the two conditions
the two conditions the two types of
of the messenger andhed of the one who
sent the messenger asbafi
mentions
of Allah and of the way that we worship
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
We only worship Allahool.
We only worship Allah in the way that
Allah has allowed us to worship him.
Allah says in the closing verse of
Then he is to work righteous deeds. What
are righteous deeds? What Muhammad has
taught us?
And that he not associate in the worship
of his Lord anyone or anything else.
That isahillah.
As a matter of fact, we just heard in
our salah tonight a few minutes ago.
[Silence]
We heard in our in the verses of tonight
of surah Bakar
Allah says, "Whoever
submits his intention and sincerity to
Allah alone and works righteous deeds."
And this is always repeated through the
Quran. Who are the people of paradise?
Those
who believe believe meaning that they
have sincerity. They worship Allah alone
work righteous deeds. Those who follow
the sunnah of the prophet Muhammad Sam.
And so Allah tells us of these details
in order that he mentions five reasons.
Number one,
he says, "Subhan,
the first reason to increase the already
disbelieving in his disbelief and
misguidance.
Number two,
so that the people of the book become
certain that this Quran is from Allah
and that the people of belief are
increased in their belief. Number four,
and so that the people who were given
the book and the believers do not become
doubtful of this book or this messenger.
And the fifth
and so that the those who have a disease
in their heart or those who disbelieve
so that they may question and say what
does Allah want with such a parable and
an analogy to give. These are the five
things he mentions. Notice that the
verse being revealed
increases the believers in faith.
Meaning that if that verse wasn't
revealed, they would have no way
of being increased in their faith
without the verse being revealed. This
means that every time you learn
something new of Islam, something new of
the Quran, a new verse of the Quran, you
have now become increased in faith and
risen a level. You cannot rise that
level
without knowledge from Allah and his
messenger sallall.aii wasallam. this
pitiful belief that we can just wander
around stumbling in the dark worshiping
Allah sloppy and in any way we think and
deem necessary at the moment and somehow
stumble our way into the graces of
Allah. This is nothing but misguidance
from a shaan. To the point that some
groups
who call themselves Muslims have even
said knowledge hinders
from true closeness to Allah.
that knowledge impedes your emotional
connection with Allah. All right?
Knowledge is too it's too many rules.
You can't get groovy with it with all
this knowledge involved dictating your
every movement. No, we don't need any
knowledge to dictate our worship of
Allah. We need to catch that feeling.
You want to see where that ends up? Look
at the Christians today, modern
Christianities,
jumping and singing and wrapping and and
dressing and and behaving wild
asses in in their places of worship like
donkeys. This is not to say that you
know Christians are donkey. We're not
saying this. We're saying that this idea
of unfettered
unfettered
feeling and worshiping Allah, however
you feel you should, as long as
your heart's in the right place, it will
lead to the Muslims, the Christians, the
Jews, the people of knowledge, the
people who were given the book to
mistreating their own places of worship
and to making their worship into
entertainment.
this is an entertainment. This is
we come to be entertained. And when they
go to their church or their synagogue,
it's like
it's a fashion show. It's the
mech gala. Everyone is trying to outdo
the other one in their outfit, in their
car, in their vehicle, in their This is
what we get when we have unfettered
sincerity. They may be very sincere in
what they're doing, but s as we have
said many times before,
sincerity
and ignorance are a very dangerous
combination.
There are few combinations more
dangerous
than sincerity mixed with ignorance.
Because the sincere is driven, but they
are driven to the worst and wrong
things.
Nothing a sincerely curious person
who is misguided and ignorant. They may
burn down their entire world around them
and say,
"We only were trying to do the best. We
had good intentions. Well, thanks. You
burned down the whole world. That was a
great great intention. That doesn't that
doesn't exempt a person from
responsibility, nor does it exonerate.
and
[Silence]
alhamdulillah.